here. Welcome to another Zoom call in the end of August. I think this actually marks seven years, I think, of doing Zoom calls.
Angie could correct me if I'm wrong, but I think it's seven years of doing Zoom calls.
And they're all on YouTube.
I do have to, I did it to do an update. I should put it on the members so that let me do it.
Remember to look at your, or anybody who's new look at your member site, hold to the member site, use the member site and updating the member site.
But I want you to do videos of the member site just today.
And look at the courses too.
Mainly the course that I'll be doing most updates on is going to be the product disease and all of course, I think that's going to be the most relevant for our observations.
And so, and it also looked at the blogs and put a lot of videos on blogs too and braces blogging a lot of onto the recipes and things.
But I do want to make about, I want to make it out to them about YouTube.
So YouTube is not where you're using currently I'll upload this video to YouTube and it's listed as unlisted. So nobody can see it. Nobody can find it.
Unless you go to the member site and on the Zoom call videos.
I'm sure all of you have done that to look at the past Zoom calls.
But YouTube just passed a ruling for a new piece of their discriminative apparatus against anybody who doesn't tow the line with the general rule of some of what are our
medical government is pushing. And they called it when they call it the new this medical misinformation act that they're going to be pulling video off of YouTube.
But we just got another video deleted by them, which is, which is hilarious because it really had nothing other was understanding our bundles are different supplement bundles that we have.
So why they would their AI would pick up that member. It's not a human being that's looking at our videos. It's AI that's picking up some verbiage I must have used in the video.
As I said, something about breast cancer is probably our breast cancer bundle video.
And so they picked up preventing breast cancer or something like that. And they they what they do is they just delete your video and then they said you and they said to be an email.
What are your videos that's been removed from your content.
I just want to worry. We're working at getting basically out of YouTube, you know, we got out on Facebook. But a couple of years ago, because of the same situation they were looking at our data, they were, you know, it's it's just very
sad the way our world is coming. And we were speaking our mind and tell people the truth about health. So
YouTube is, you know, old by Google and they are getting worse and worse. And I think in the next year, we're going to be completely off of YouTube. We're actually working.
Just to work in that building our old video platform.
So we'll have more information on that, but I just want to let you know what's going on with YouTube, if ever I can't upload a zoom call on to YouTube like that was a few weeks ago, because they banned us for a week.
Discipline and band off YouTube for a week. I had uploaded directly the hotspot. And that's the software that we use for the never site. So we'll just do that. And just continue to be protective. But it is just a run around that we're getting from the powers that be
constantly. So I just want you to know what our fight is and that would be, you know, a good thing to pray for us for projection that way, because they're just, they're trying to get rid of practitioners like me anyway they can. And they'll get rid of our information scrubbed off the internet.
If they could possibly do that. So we're trying to host it in protective whole our website is hosted and protected by people in a company that believes in
first amendment rights and freedom of speech. And they're very conservative organization that
it's a very same place to host our website.
But it's just it's just okay. Sorry, not for that. Let's get to your questions. Question number one. What is the rebuilder?
Does it have to plug into the right or is it a standalone device? Will it help all derves and not just those negatively affected by human?
So a rebuilder is a standalone device. It's not made by true right. This is what it looks like. It looks like a like a little tens unit. It's very small. This would fit into the palm of your hand.
And then wire connects to the top up here and bifurcates into two wires in their little TD pads and the rubber pads and you put them in a bucket that is a split bucket.
Not like you're in a pro way bucket where both your feet go in the same water as a split bucket. So each foot goes into a different, you know, bucket of water.
And then you put those in there and you in the pads and there you turn it up. And it's a little electric stem that goes through there and stimulates your feet. You can do it on your hands too, but then you have to somebody obviously turn it up.
And then that stimulates the nerves at 5.8 rehertz and can help rebuild damaged nerves. It doesn't detoxify. So understand the rebuilder is not specific to nerves that are damaged by chemo therapy. It's not specific to nerves that are damaged by high blood pressure blood sugar like diabetic neuropathy.
It's it's not specific to any nerve, but it's but it is going to be most helpful for a fair and pathways, meaning pathways that go from the skin back to the brain.
Meaning pathways that carry pain pathways that carry touch deep touch like touch of vibration hot and cold. Those are your a fair and pathways that are carrying information from receptors in the skin in the tissue back to the brain.
Those in the pathway pathways that are damaged most readily when a person has diabetes and end up with their empathy with all all forms of neuropathy and state bird pathways that are damaged.
So because they're high more highly metabolic, they're going to uptake chemo more than other cells.
And they'll be they can be destroyed by chemo therapy. Now the rebuilder does not detoxify. So you still have to use your iron pro wave to help pull junk out of your body. You still have to use detox methods nutritionally, et cetera, but the rebuilder will help rebuild those pathways.
We sell this in our store, we used to have a discount for patients.
And then they call me and scolded me because we can't sell it in our store for less than what they sell it for, but if you if any of our patients want this, we give a hundred dollars off the cost to our patients, but you'd have to call in the order.
And so just just do that because we want to try to sell it at close to our cost as possible. So it's just that we had it that way that rebuilder call us said we have to keep a minimal pricing index.
I don't know any online stuff. So we had to change it back to the price.
So that is available in our store.
And again, that would be for someone who has neuropathy. If you don't have any neuropathy, then you wouldn't need to rebuild.
I was planning on sending it in a cheek swap today Monday, but Saturday was an IV was an IV started coming out and instead today I'm at bed stat getting a steroid shot and a prescription for more person talking to boys and IV.
I have it really bad. I assume I should wait to send the cheek swabs. How long? So this so given the rest of this question.
This person is talking about poison. I poison IV started coming out beating maybe a rash from poison. I've started coming out of the skin.
So how long should I wait before I do a cheek swab? Well, the poison IV rashes get effected cheek swab for cancer. So you could still do the send the cheek swab for cancer. Also, what's your recommended recommendation for treating poison IV.
OTC over the color. I really want to avoid the shot, but the poison IV is too bad this time. Don't PSA don't pet strange dogs. You don't know what they've been.
So there's a lot of treatment things for poison IV that you could search on the internet.
I remember when we lived in the woods, we had lots of poison IV and I got to the point where I was basically just immune to it. I could literally pick it out of my garden and I didn't even break out. So we just got to that point.
We have poison IV where our office is now because our office is a whole so down 12 acres. And I get exposed to poison IV every year, get a little bit of a rash as long as I tried out through to it.
I don't get it too bad of an issue, but there are some people that end up developing at IGG, IGG antibodies to poison IV and then they break out really bad and they get really blistered and such.
But it is the, I think it's both your cereal acid oil that is really the contaminated to poison IV. So the
you have to get the oil off your body. So using you can't just wash the skin with water when you're exposed to poison IV because it won't, because oil repels water. So you have to use some sort of oil
clear to get it off your body. So many people recommend some of the cleaners that would be used some of the solvents that would be used as hand cleaners for like mechanics.
I can't remember the name of them right now, but I used to have them. I think it was cool for something like that that was in a jar. I had in my garage in my workbench so that when I got really oily skin from working with my chains are something I would grab so that I can clean off my hands using something like that that's oil
soluble that will help pull that out of off the skin is the best thing. Once you already get the reaction of poison IV, there are anti inflammatory things you could do for the nutritional standpoint.
But still it's hard to get to the skin. Obviously most people are using the steroid creams and stuff for poison IV and that gets to be difficult.
I had a patient years ago that had a company that sold poison IV treatment stuff, but I can't remember the name of that company actually gave me some of the product to try.
I believe I still haven't somewhere. I've never had to use it. My kids have never had to use it. We don't have poison IV in our house. We really have 20 acres of our house. We just don't have poison IV there.
So we haven't had to use it. So I just I think probably sell their stuff on Amazon. I would look out Amazon for a poison IV treatment and there's probably some good products out there.
This guy used to score that they started their company because they were one of their kids or something had a form of a horrible reaction and so they did the research and put the products together.
I would try something like that.
But could the steroids interfere? The question is really could the steroids interfere with the sheikh's law. No, if I know that you're on steroids, I'll take that into consideration. But if you're if you're
maybe you should wait at least a week and tell your mom the steroids are said it in just to be safe.
If you're at a crisis mode, we can work around it, but you're not at a crisis mode. So let's wait till you're off the steroids, give it a good three or four days off the steroids and then you're the sheikh's law.
Is it okay for me to use the infrared sauna while I'm on a cortical steroid for poison IV?
I would say no for a couple of reasons.
You know, steroids are going to be at a flammatory sauna is inflammatory. You know, that's what you're trying to do is to create a fever state.
And you're kind of going against it. Plus you'll number two, you will detox the steroids through the skin much quicker and you'll get less benefit from them.
Number three, you could actually spread the poison IV around because you're going to be sweating more. So I would stay away from the sauna personally.
While you're on the steroids for the reason that you detox the cortical steroids quicker, you're going to decrease the you're going to increase an inflammatory response.
You're by fighting against the cortical steroids and the simple fact that you have poison IV that you can spread more.
What is NAC? NAC is an acetylcystine. I wouldn't be good for a person who has estrogen-driven breast cancer. So an acetylcystine is a precursor for glutathione.
So that's why would you take an acetylcystine?
It would take an acetylcystine for the purpose of increasing glutathione reduction in the cell. So what is glutathione?
So don't confuse glutathione with glutamine, or the words sound the same. They're not even close to the same thing completely different.
So glutathione is the main intracellular antioxidant. So remember, we're exposed to oxidizing agents.
Have a purpose in our body. Everything is at all good, yours are all bad. So you hear about oxidizing agents. So that's all bad. Well, it's not all bad. You need oxidizing agents to kill bacteria to help you kill bacteria to help kill viruses.
It's good to have oxidizing agents. But once virus gets inside the cell and causes an oxidation that's going on and damages the cell, so you want antioxidants inside the cell.
glutathione is your main antioxidant inside of a cell. One of the issues with oxidizing agents is that we're exposed to a lot of oxidizing agents. Oxidizing agents are poisons.
So poisons, toxins, heavy metals, pesticides, herbicides, all those things are oxidizing agents. They're in abundance and they can damage cell membranes.
They can damage causing cancer. They can get inside a cell and damage the nucleus causing cancer. They can cause death of a cell. They can damage the mitochondria. They can damage other organelles in the cell.
They can wreak havoc and people would argue that our exposure to the high level of oxidizing agents is a cause of the majority of our ill health today that our ancestors never experienced.
And that is true. So our body, we're made, God created us to have an antioxidant system. The antioxidant system inside the cell, there's multiple, but the main one is the production and recycling of glutathione.
It's so important that you don't just, you don't burn through glutathione, you recycle glutathione. Well, cysteine is an amino acid that is essential to help recycle glutathione.
So glutathione is used to break down an oxidant, and therefore it's reduced that it needs to be recycled again in order to be reactivated to be used again. So cysteine is an important amino acid to help with glutathione production and recycling of glutathione. That's an acetyl cysteine.
But a person with cancer take an acetyl cysteine.
So back to understanding glutathione. So is an acetyl cysteine an important thing to take for a person with cancer or a person that has a lot of oxidizing agents person that has been exposed to a lot of toxins person that exposed to mold person that is exposed to glyphosate.
Well, to be, it's one step better than taking an acetyl cysteine would be taking glutathione. The problem is in years past, glutathione was very poorly absorbed. The form, the forms of glutathione we had in the 80s, 90s, and early 2000s.
It wasn't worth really taking you to absorb it. We used to have people put it in water and then demulize it. That was better, much better absorbed.
But now we have better forms of glutathione. Even in a capsule form, we have good forms of glutathione.
Supplement company will use these better forms. And even the best form of glutathione is a liposomal glutathione very well absorbed. So even bypassing the recycling process, you're increasing glutathione stores and sells.
Glutathione is essential inside every cell and in the liver to help you detoxifying places.
Back to should every person be taking glutathione or acetyl cysteine. Well, it depends. If a person is doing chemotherapy, then they should not be doing glutathione or acetyl cysteine or any glutathione or antioxidants.
That during at least a 48 hour window after the IV chemotherapy, because you're now negating chemotherapy as an oxidized agent.
So someone happy that balance, but can someone who's not doing the chemotherapy take glutathione?
Yes, doesn't mean that every person on your planet should be taking glutathione or anacetyl cysteine. Well, not necessarily you do get it in your foods cysteine is an amino acid.
It's in an animal proteins and in plant proteins. So again, it's like you could be overloading all the supplements that you're taking. I don't love people to have that issue either.
I'm taking a couple of the supplements from biotics research. I understand they are no longer on the website, but we can still request that it was my understanding that we could go and don't.
We need to order other order asking for these products to be added. I've done that twice without receiving it. So we need to call.
Do we need to call and talk to someone to get these biotic research supplements? So yes, if you if anybody ever puts a note on an order and you don't receive what's on that note.
You have to understand that our system, our store is set up through a company called Shopify and those notes are sometimes very difficult to see.
If you don't notice that there's this little teeny little icon that on an order, it's real easy to miss. So if you didn't get anything in your order regardless of whether you put a note or it was just missed, make sure you just call the office and we'll get that shipped out to you.
I did build to Megan who asked this question and we'll get that product out to you if that today did not go on.
So if you ever have any issue with a product, you can't find something on the store, don't get frustrated, just call the office and we'll help you with your order.
That's what we're here for. I might, I might even see seems to have use as an on toxic chemo therapeutic agent that can shrink tumors.
That means said there are many studies that say it doesn't work. What's your experience and understanding it didn't, didn't cutters couldn't do this at one time.
I also understand that life will so more vitamin C can achieve IV levels of vitamin C in your bloodstream can this replace IV vitamin C. What's typical protocol for IV vitamin C and or liposomal vitamin C for reducing tumor size by tone of 10,000.
Well, it has to IV therapy clinics. Okay, last part of the question. First, yeah, please IV therapy clinics are copied up around little tones even so that's kind of nice.
What's not ice is the cost. It still can be anywhere between 150 to 250 dollars to do a session of IV vitamin C.
First part of the question IV vitamin C seems to have not toxic people therapeutic effects, but there are many studies that say that it doesn't work.
Well, I just wrote a blog just the other day and it's titled is research real or bias lonely because if you read my book, you realize that there's what's called publication bias.
The publication bias in research not to hold on this point of this research piece many studies say and it doesn't work, but publication bias is is very real.
That means like if a drug company is trying to get a drug pass, they will actually put study out to dozens and dozens of places, universities, independent doctors.
And that's just her law worked for a neurologist who was not literally never into her clinic that all she did is make money ready and studies.
And she my so my sister in law just sat there and had these epileptic patients coming in, some of them got a placebo, some of them got the drug.
And then she would have to meet with them on a weekly basis and she'd have to write out any side effects symptoms, she had a fill in this form that was produced by the drug company.
And she would that's the neurologist just made both those buckles running these studies and never even showed up at work.
But nice gig, I guess, huh. And then the problem is is that so the the drug companies will get these, you know, let's say 50 studies back after six months of running this drug study.
And let's say out of the 50 let's be worst case scenario 45 showed ill effects and it didn't work.
It didn't in any better matter fact they had all these negative side effects, but five of them showed slight improvement.
They'll only publish the best two studies, the rest of the 48 just don't ever get published. So in a very real sense for medical literature for any data for any statistical clarification of the efficacy of a drug, those studies never happened.
The only ones that happen are the one or the two that got published that could have been extremely skewed because the doctor slash university or wherever, whoever sent the results back wanted to continue to make money from Pfizer.
So they skewed the results in their favor so that they could keep money pouring into the system.
That's I mean, you think, oh, you're cynical about sitting. This is just the truth. So if it's just what goes on. So if a drug company wanted to slander, you know, a nutrient or vitamin C or, you know, anything like that, they'll just run a study.
A number of years ago, they read a study on vitamin E in the heart. They purposely used alpha to clopperol, which is the outer most shell in the vitamin E, which everybody knows that's not the protective part of the vitamin E vitamin E has four outer shell to copper all in
four inner total triadols. That's what makes up a whole food vitamin E molecule. When they use only that outer shell alpha to clopperol as the as this in the study and it showed that people who were taking that form of vitamin E for their heart actually did worse. So then this giant study and all these articles and CNN reports and vitamin E is bad for your heart.
That any nutrition that's telling you to take vitamin E for your heart isn't quite the blah, blah, blah, blah. It's it's just purposely skewed the study. It's just it's unbelievable.
And if you haven't been awake during the last few years of COVID, how they just absolutely just ruined the lives and careers of doctors and people that have been trying to help people with I'm erected and other natural aids for viruses.
You need to you need to open up your eyes to see what really goes on. So I'm not trying to be cynical and just trying to be an honest observer of what's going on in our times.
So I'm all for looking at studies, but you have to look at them with a very critical eye. That being said, I don't believe that vitamin C is going to work on everybody else and I do believe that there's a lot of alternative things out there that are skewed in the favor of an alternative thing too.
I'm too bad for somebody asked a question down here that we'll get to it. A second is next question. Oh, it's the next question that this person is thinking about going to this clinic that says that they have documented success of 90% remissions.
Boy, that would send a red flag nine flag call right away that they're even able to to make a statement like that, even if it was true. They have to be very careful of these types of statements.
This is what gets alternative doctors in trouble. And I think it gives us a bad name as well, and you start making claims that that it's just how do you define that, you know, it's, you know, where practice of medicine as a five year survival rate, you know, which creates rubber numbers themselves, because if you live one day after the five years after diagnosis.
You're considered cured even though you might have lived a horrific life and died the day after that five years. So you're pushed in the list is cured, which is very, you know, skewed data. So it's really hard to truly keep data on what is the true remission.
Because I feel like I've been remissioned, but I could have cancer growing in time right now and I could go into a full blown reoccurrence at any given time. You just, it's a day by day dealing with things. So I get it. And you just want to make the best decisions and you're trying to do your research to make the best decisions.
And what should I do with IV vitamin C? And should I go to a clinic like this, who's touting pretty high success rates, it's very difficult to make decisions when you're trying to deal with something that's back in your life.
Let's get back to this question. I've been able to learn. I think IV vitamin C can be very helpful, but I don't think it's a cure all end off for everybody. And if it's something that you want to try, I'd say, by all means, try it. There really is no downside to vitamin C.
So by all means, give it a try. Can you use liposomal vitamin C in lieu of IV vitamin C? Yes, it no. You'd have to take a lot of liposomal vitamin C to get up to an equivalent dosage of, let's say, 75 grams of IV vitamin C. So typically, if you're going to go in for IV vitamin C, you start out at a lower dosage in the lower dosages.
And on your weight, maybe 15 to 20, maybe even 25 grams in your first sessions, and you slowly work up to 35, 50, and you slowly work it up to 75 by pencil people over 100 grams of vitamin C.
Now, it would be really difficult to get equivalent dosage of 175 grams of vitamin C doing liposomal.
I guess it still be a lot less expensive. And if you don't have a place around you to go, you could still possibly do that.
The dosage of liposomal vitamin C, it's typically said that, you know, one gram of liposomal vitamin C is equivalent to about five grams of IV vitamin C.
I don't know. That was statistics from a several years ago. I don't know if that's still thought to be true. But if you could use that type of measurement to try to figure out if you're going to get the same dose.
The benefit of doing liposomals, you could do it daily versus going in months or twice a week doing IV. And then the IV, you might get this major therapeutic benefit flush dosage.
But then it has a half life in your body and it's going to be gone. So you think, well, maybe that's better. You get this major flush and then it's flushing out.
But maybe, but maybe it would be better if you had just a little bit less dosage on a daily basis. So I think it's really worth experimenting with with each person.
Everybody might be different to how they respond to it. Some people might respond better to a super high dose. Once a week, some people maybe a medium dose in liposomal on a daily basis. It's worth experimenting with.
I'm not saying you don't look at research. I'm just saying that you look at it with a critical. And I think you should look at everything with critical.
Yeah, I just think that's the world we live in.
Okay, so next question I touched on. There's a clinic in a temporary Arizona that tells 90% remissions.
Dr. Hubert points out that following their protocols patients who do not include sugar. That is, they're doing more of a keto diet.
They have a 90% successful successful in going into revision while those who do each sugar are at about 36%.
I would say that that statistic has some merit that you can pull those numbers completely, but I think people do better, the less glucose they consume.
No, not every cancer is only going to feed off of glucose. I do think that that all cells would prefer to use glucose. So cancer cells as well, they'll still use glucose.
So glycolysis is the normal, prefer method of production of ATP, you know, in all cells. So if you could submit that, that's, that is good.
That means that I think you have to be switching up your diet at different intervals in order to keep a cancer at bay. So I have a thinking of a true protocol has not been working as well as I would like.
And the one reason is that I'm consistently cheating that it comes to sugar. Yes, I use low low glycemic sugar, such as monk fruit.
But while at first I go off it completely, I started having high car meals and then for a time and chocolates, tried to stay with dark chocolate, almost every day, or not very ice cream bar on occasion, while I dropped that now, I know I'm very often on occasion, but mostly with high sugar fruit or juice, high fruit sugar fruits, which I thought was okay.
But it creeps out, going to dinner with friends doesn't always happen. Yeah, I know it's hard, but I do think that, you know, that that's, you know, you can get some, should get around them somewhat by doing it.
It's fast, but still if you're cheating, if you're, especially if your cancer is growing, you have to get super, super serious and strict on your diet, but even people that are on a really super strict ketogenic diet for a long, for a long time, their cancer can fight another fuel source.
So you have to be willing to pivot pretty quick. So if it starts feeding mainly off glutamine after there's no glucose, and you've been in remission for three to six months, and now the cancer starts pivoting to feed off of amino acids, then you have to be able to pivot quickly and get out of the mindset that I can't eat any carbs.
So it's, it's just a balancing act. So again, I would say, you know, try, if you feel like your cancer is growing, try to get really super serious about like a more ketogenic type diet for a period of time, see what happens, do testing, and see what happens.
So you can see if there is a, if that was a piece, just like the, I said, with testing yourself with the vitamin C, just make sure you're not making too many changes, same times you don't know what is actually working if you're, if you're planning success.
So as megastase juice have value in shrinking cancer tumors, megastase juice, I think mainly works as an antioxidant, so I think it can be really been beneficial as far as helping you detox.
I haven't seen anything with megastase juice with shrinking tumors though.
I started the Artemisinin program today and take this by six to seven a.m. daily now, I got the DMSL also thank you for picking that up hopefully that will help with some inflammatory areas too.
I just wanted to make sure my coffee, I do daily about 10 a.m. will not remove the Artemisinin in my system.
No, I mean, if the Artemisinin is circulated your body to go through the liver to be detoxified, yes, do it a copy of it is going to hopefully help with the detox occasion what's going on in base one base two of your liver.
If the Artemisinin is trying to go through that pathway, I would say, you know, you don't, I would say go continue to do the coffee animal physiological standpoint does make sense to stop that.
You're not doing Artemisinin as an oxidizing agent like a like a chemo therapy, so where you admit caught the animal during chemo therapy.
So I would say to change that.
Out of curiosity why are amino acids not beneficial, well, challenged with cancer, do they promote cancer growth.
I touch on that back here cancer is always trying to fight a fuel source so the fuel source most often referred is glucose, but then it can use authority and glutamine amino acids as a fuel source too, so you're trying to cut off that fuel source.
So you are you are going to be consuming amino acids, though, you're not going to go protein free of your diet, you need to be amino acids are the building blocks proteins, you need you need to be the essence for everything in your body, that's how you make enzymes, it's how you make.
So you need those building blocks you just don't, there may be some sources that are feeding the cancer and you want to try to eliminate bones.
You asked me to have a blood draw in the month I just ordered the female to your marker handle by just wondering what all will be assessed by memory is failing me.
Well, I'd have to look at it as well with the female toer marker panel is testing five tumor markers most commonly seed with with the female tumors.
I think it's CA 53 CA 99 CA 125 CA and one other one that's different than the male to her panel male to a marker panel which would also include PSA maybe not the 53.
So yeah, it's not testing for it's not a CBC, which is a complete one called it's not a complete metabolic panel so that would be different to your doctor order that just well.
If we want to look at those things.
I'm a measure of a glucose and it remains higher than we'd like it to be the lowest I've been able to get it is 87 very frustrated because I've cut out all honey, maple syrup, also trying to minimize fruit, increased meat, still doing a lot of vegetables as much organic as possible the only process foods.
I do our occasional gluten free better pasta I do eat some rice for a starch lately more potatoes than I should.
Thanks so much.
Yeah, it's it's you know people think that I'm just going to you know reduce glucose out of my diet my glucose is going to come down well anybody that has.
Has diabetes understands it doesn't just not that simple so reducing glucose is the start but your cell membranes healing how damaged are your cell membranes how healthy is your pancreas.
You know all this plays a role that it takes time for those things to heal so you just got to be patient with yourself was not.
100% tied to your diet my stomach still sticks out and I can't figure out why.
Well I can figure out my mind sticks out but that's what it would still.
I've had a good weight eat clean take all my supplements and many have to do with detoxification I'm asking not because of vanity but because I wonder if I miss you to step of detoxification or something else.
I know that my gut health is so important while dealing with cancer someone's suggestion I should I could be it could be related to cortisol every see doctor recall those new article about adding carbs back to the diet once you resolve insulin resistance something he never thought she'd say.
Okay so I need more information that my stomach sticks up you know are you bloated do you is it inflammation is there the sighties present is it always or is it only after a meal is it you know there's lots of questions that need to be asked with this question.
That that lead to different things certainly it's not that you're just missing a supplement so I made some major causes of abdominal bloating can be you know hidden age pylori infections dysbiosis which you know.
When you're dealing with digestion you have to start from the top down you know is this person of adequate.
HCl production so that they're digesting proteins and carbs in their in their stomach in the first part of the swallow test and call the do I do they have number two good production of pancreatic enzymes and health in the pancreas that's released number three does this person.
Have issues with their gallbladder major cause of bloating right there because if you have issues your gallbladder that's what I call phase four of the detoxification process then you're going to have issues so that could be an issue or you know if you have gallbladder issues well the best way to know is to get an ultrasonic the gallbladder to see if you have sludge or stills in the gallbladder but how else could you get hints that you have gallbladder issues do you have issues.
Issues eating when you eat fatty foods to give you a little tummy ache some people are sensitive no sensitive enough to know that some people just kind of inherently why I don't eat a lot of fatty foods well why because it bothers me so well there you go that's why.
A hint that you have gallbladder issues so gallbladder issues are very calmness even more common with females over 40.
That can cause that low lead issue those things all can lead to damage got material layers and got permeability issues and can leak got issues.
Testile dysbiosis.
It can happen regardless of whether the person has cancer it can be completely you know separate from a person's cancer diagnosis so comorbidity but not really completely related to anything else going on with the cancer.
Very common issues you just talked about right there so how would you know that how would you dress that they're certainly labs that you can run to deal with those kind of things but you started with.
I think I think I have a long post about HCL and H. Kylo right that would be helpful to look at that first and follow some of those steps.
As far as adding carbs back to your diet lets you resolve the insulin resistance issue i'm totally I do believe that we're not supposed to be carb free in our diet or dealing with cancer all that kind of stuff through goes out the window we're trying not to fuel the cancer and things so you have to get back to our previous questions that we talked about that so it's not just about insulin resistance that we're talking about that we're not trying to fuel the cancer.
Okay some questions that came in my right gets warm sometimes hot at night is that okay yes that's normal your bulb is going to get very hot that's why the new bulbs have a little hole in the plastic to let that out.
Is there anything you know about the hole in the bulb cover that to block it with the sheet where you do your best it will get warm even if it's open to the air thus I avoid way if I'm avoiding dairy um yes I would not use away protein do you see the way in that form I would use a key protein.
Um or something like that if you're using a protein drink.
Boys and I we talked about here's doctor who will viewers determine their results a couple times if I've received free almost expired or expired product which is very kind of you this happened on the water I received yesterday the product is called aloevia entourage to it is a liquid with a.
liquid with a dropper how should I take this and what will it offer me so whatever if you do get a free product because it's because it's near expiration it's not because it's bad um all our nutrients are good for two to three years after expiration we can't sell it but it's close to expiration so we give them away.
Aloevia entourage is a CBD so CBD is very good for a lot of things help decrease inflammation in the brain whereby it helps decrease anxiety and help decrease pain.
It attaches to the cannabinoid receptors all yourselves have cannabinoid receptors and it works as a stimulant to detoxification and anti inflammation.
So it would CBD be good for everybody to take sure it's just expensive so it's not something I recommend all the time it's something that's used in the event is all protocol and it's something that we sell a lot of because a lot of people are in the CBD for the cure that does a lot of missing information out there that it cares everything.
CBD is beneficial and most there's really no downsides of CBD except the cost.
A lot of people use CBD a night before they go to bed it can help calm living health and sleep bed.
Hi Dr. Cutters could you recommend a good digestion enzyme for me blood type A low HCl.
So I would use our clear digest clear digest has HCl and a complete fix of enzymes.
I picked that one to private label because it's not super high in HCl which can be irritant to as people are healing they're got the healing they're stomach they're starting on try to heal.
So I would use the clear digest to take that with every meal that's our private label clear digest that's a good one.
I will email you the local article and talks about cancer to even though he's suggesting the cards.
All right great thank you so much my stomach is latter in the morning but I haven't noticed a pattern with fatty foods I was taking digestion from from decide for health but didn't seem to help.
Okay so digestive is our clear digest so digestive so I can't remember if I made a video about this.
But I think it's I think it's in the blog post it's really really important to make a video about it because the proper way to dose.
Hydrochloric acid in digestive enzymes is really to looking for the blog here is really to take okay so let's say a person has bloating issues and we're going to start at the top that's what you do when you're dealing with digestion.
So to start at the top and you.
Then the top is well there's your looking at them whether you are able to produce saliva to be able to produce talent that's going to help break down carbohydrates and you know before they get to your stomach whether you're chewing your food you have to chew your food and order to use the crate.
Hydrochloric acid that's why I'm not a big fan of you chewing gum a lot because when you chew gum you're stimulating hydrochloric acid production when you don't have food coming down there and then once it gets to your stomach you need to produce enough hydrochloric acid yeah here's the blog post let me change my share screen here.
And we can see it.
No.
And it's h unicobacter pylori information and care talks about h pylori what h pylori does and the importance of HCl stage one we move a dietary antigens testing for antigen stuff.
But starting at the top for digestion really is starting with a digestive enzyme so that you have HCl in your in your stomach when you have food and I like it that just depends on it is also going to have digest the product that's also that digestive enzymes.
But you have to dose that HCl up to the point that it's going to work so you could say well I started taking what it really didn't help.
You got to dose it up I've had people that have to take seven eight nine eight nine of the clear digest or a similar product per meal for a week or two before the balloons started going down and then you start titrating down so you titrate often and then you titrate down.
Some people there their stomach is in such bad shape maybe possibly ulcers that they can't even take HCl they have to let's say they take clear digest and oh my gosh it gave me a stomachache when I took that clear digest or any HCl product did well then in this article it says then you have to go do the apple cider vinegar test.
You take two titles builds of apple cider vinegar so put the HCl the clear digest product away for a little bit and you just use apple cider vinegar if that causes burning as well then we got to take another step backwards and you got a heel that got with products like clear GI if you don't have cancer which has got a lot of different herbs in it to help heal that got lighting but.
It doesn't have some glutamated it so you have to be careful of using that when you have cancer where you can just go with just some of those individual products that are in there like deglycerated licorice and and remember all the ingredients that are in that and start healing that got lighting so this would be a person if they have burning they definitely have a bolster so they have to heal that first and then we go back to this step and we.
And we start giving the product with HCl and digestive enzymes and then you dose it up you tight trade it up to well by building all gone and now you start tight trading down you don't need to stay on four five six seven of these per meal for the rest of your life you tight trade down so that you know eventually you don't necessarily take any that's the goal your stomach is producing it up HCl.
And I think I did make a video a number of years back the importance of HCl everybody's talking about optimizing their cancer well one of the reasons why your tissue the tissues have an imbalance of acidity is because you're not making enough HCl in your stomach.
I was absolutely with my love or my liver well has everything to do it because the production of HCl by your primal glands of your stomach actually gives off a base that goes into your blood and alkalizes your tissues.
So everybody works so when you eat food and your stomach is healthy and you produce HCl and your stomach makes more HCl then you actually alkalize your tissue well one of the issues when i'm not making a lot of HCl because I have.
You know not treating my stomach well I've eaten a bunch of crap and it's damaged my stomach lining so I don't make HCl very well and then I end up with Hpilora which decreases HCl production even more so then I'm not creating an alkaline substances that are going to alkalize my tissues are not creating my carbonyls that are alkalizing my tissue.
So then it's a negative cycle no Hpilora which is a gram positive bacteria is created in over abundance in my stomach it gets worse that could actually create a gastric cancer this is the cause solely of gastric and do I know ulcers this is one of the top five causes of cardiovascular disease.
And it will deal your dysfunction very very important to deal with the gut you know not one that says you heal the gut you heal everything but if you don't address the gut you know you are doing that at your own risk because it just causes also it's problems so this is a good blog post I have to actually create some videos to go on this blog post to.
Oh I did I created a couple but these this one's a whole new but look at this I'll actually create some videos that will help with that too.
Is your cancer book no longer a free download.
I don't know I think we actually changed it to be a part only a part of it be a free download and the reason wasn't we got so many complaints of people that would know my staff would say well download in buckets for free and they'd say I download it it's too long so that we actually compartmentalize it broke down we surely get part of it as a free download.
You could order it on our story you could order it on Amazon don't.
I miss this I was taking two with lunch and three with that are tolerated and find my local practitioner also test me they didn't test with.
Okay so well thank you decision there.
All right well we're at about that time so I think it's time to close for the night I think everybody for being here.
As that you continue to pray for us we are continuing to pray for you though that we love all of you and thank you so much for going to.